[Music]  hello he asking me on a date she didn't  seem that impressed you clean up pretty  good yourself  you two look fine miss Eden we're on a  date  very nice took you long enough to ask  so why did you give up your life on  earth we boarded the Avalon with the  destination  120 years hibernation means we'll wake  up in a new century on a new planet but  a year  though everything changed  anybody here uh  [Music]  you know what's going on but nobody else  is awake I think something went wrong  with the hibernation pies we woke up too  soon  and years too soon  less kami we should go back to sleep we  can't  we love you  something's wrong something big  what do we do  do you trust me  the ship is going to go  there's something I have to tell you  there's a reason we woke up early  [Music]  my name is Alice this is my story